comparing democratic socialism to
traditional socialism or god forbid
communism is fear-mongering it's an
accurate but it's actually it's actually
pretty reasonable we need to unite and
work together if we're all going to get
through this sounds like socialism to me
democratic socialism what's the
difference huge difference except that
it's not here's Bernie Sanders when
asked describing democratic socialism
and what democratic socialism is about
is saying that it is immoral and wrong
that the top one-tenth of one percent in
this country own almost 90 percent
almost owned almost as much wealth as
the bottom 90% you see every other major
country providing health care to all
people as a right except the United
States those are some of the principles
that I believe in and I think we should
look to countries like Denmark like
Sweden and Norway and learn from what
they have accomplished for their working
people this is pivotal because there's a
myth going around that democratic
socialism is inherently different from
traditional socialism Bernie Sanders did
not articulate a worldview there at all
he just pointed to things that have
existed since the beginning of time told
you that you should be angry that you
deserve stuff and presented you with a
Christmas wish list that's not a
worldview that's how you buy votes it's
time for who do you trust
allow me to contrast if someone asked me
what is conservatism or federalism or
constitutionalism whatever you want to
call it pretty simple my worldview
inherently believes that individuals
when left and given the freedom to make
their own decisions tend to do so more
effectively than government bureaucrats
in Washington also I believe that it is
morally imperative to provide people
with said freedom and liberties that's
it that's it I didn't promise you any
free sheep and we'll get into the Nitty
Gritty but the macro is first because
we'll come back to reference this of the
two worldviews there is only one that
allows and acknowledges human nature and
one that necessitates humans be
inherently altruistic particularly those
in government with a D next to their
name completely immune to corruption
justice and security to my new empire
your new empire don't make me kill you
where's my worldview allows for the
human nature of some people being good
some people being turd nuggets and
allowing them to make their own
decisions and the invisible hand of
market forces to mitigate the damage as
opposed to the damage that can be done
in a centralized power right away before
we get into the nerdy math and we will
you have to decide what it is that you
believe because right away the
Democratic socialists will try and poke
holes in your argument but what a lot of
people may not realize is that America
is kind of already a socialist country
some of the most obvious are things like
Medicare and Social Security
free K through 12 education national
parks prisons in the whole justice
system the Postal Service disposal of
your toilet waste even the army are all
socialist programs leftists inevitably
try and paint into the corner that
anything provided by government at all
equates to socialism and that comes back
to the worldview you need to understand
what is the legitimate role of
government particularly in the United
States honestly have you ever asked
yourself that fundamental question
everything stems from it the good thing
is we have pretty clear blueprints the
Constitution is how the Declaration of
Independence is why definitely read
those allow me to give you analogy that
my dad provided with me and I think is
appropriate here the role of the
government as per the documents that we
have is very similar to that of a hockey
referees specifically hockey you'll see
why in a second the job of hockey
referee is to ensure the safety of the
players and ensure people are obeying
the rules in a way that keeps the pace
of the game keeping the players ie the
citizens safe that would mean that the
military some form of police force is of
course a legitimate role of government
having regulations in place to ensure
that people don't steal or screw other
people of course that's a legitimate
role of government anything beyond that
purview is considered incidental and the
referee in hockey keeps his whistle in
his pocket also there's a certain
element of cell
regulation to hockey not seen in other
sports which one can appreciate dude
Robert has got to come Jam he goes down
to contrast that with a European
socialists in soccer very clearly
defined role the referees job is not to
pick winners losers high scores to
provide medical assistance to be a
waterboy or a cheerleader or even to
draft the team's so I don't want to get
too far off into the weeds but I find it
funny that Democratic socialists used
the post office as an example for
success the post office was awful until
surprised FedEx provided competition
overnight shipping two days shipping it
didn't exist it got there when it got
there you hoped also before FedEx
tracking numbers didn't exist that was
your post office you want to see
government-run health care take that and
add cancer schools are another example
your parents were raised without a
federal Department of Education they
still had public schools they were
funded by their municipalities in their
states and guess what results are pretty
similar most of your parents are smarter
than you and that's the beauty again of
the worldview of constitutionalism
there's a very limited role of the
federal government in DC but states and
municipalities have the right to enact
government services that the federal
government does not if one state wants
to tax you out of existence to provide
schools and free weed to everybody
they're free to do so just as surely a
decent state doesn't have to again when
accounting for human nature you want a
decentralization of government power
this groundwork has to be laid here
because it's pivotal that you understand
the difference between your opinion how
you would like systems to work versus
how they are legally designed to operate
so to be fair let's go to Democratic
socialists of America and their
description of democratic socialism
Democratic socialists believe that both
the economy and society should be run
democratically to meet public needs not
to make profits for a few now right away
they say that because people here
democracy and believe that it's somehow
inherently Noble and subconsciously
delineates between socialism and
democratic socialism there there is no
difference it's why Vladimir Lenin
famously said democracy is indispensable
to socialists so you may want those
things but right off the bat the United
States is not a democracy it was never
designed to be a democracy and it will
never be a democracy so long as the
Constitution stand the
United States has always been a
constitutional representative Republic
why and how is it different because the
founding fathers understood that for
freedom to be maintained it was pivotal
that the rights of the minority were not
entirely beholden to the ever-changing
will of the majority see pure democracy
sounds nice but in reality it's mob rule
which is why it inevitably collapses
again you're not accounting for human
nature if everyone has a vote they're
going to vote in their own self-interest
and the mob will vote to take stuff from
the minority I want I want I want me be
mine now a good example would be when
people first came to the United States
and colonies under John Smith Prager
University is a great video on this
originally the goal was the betterment
of the community not the individuals so
grain food resources were communal and
people took what they needed what
inevitably happened is some people were
more productive than others and the
system began collapsing and people
starved that invariably
happens with some model of socialism
it's just a matter of time and when that
time comes you have a decision to make
either you go to full-fledged communism
where the government has to control all
aspects of Commerce or you go the other
way free-market enterprise capitalism
which is what John Smith did saying okay
this isn't working everyone you're in
charge of yourself and prompted the
famous phrase he who does not work does
not eat which he was quoting from the
Bible yada yada yada fast for hundreds
of years you have an iPhone six again
human nature if if you yoke yaks if you
yoke two yaks or a few yaks I don't know
how many can you yoke the yoke yaks I
don't think the yoke acts
I think the yoke yaks they yoke the yak
if you yoke them together they are going
to move as fast as the slowest yak
centralized forms of government do this
they pull people back they're incapable
of pulling people forward which is why
Lenin famously said of socialism the
goal of socialism is communism okay
let's go right back to the Democratic
socialists own website Democratic
socialists do not want to create an
all-powerful government bureaucracy
today corporate executives who answer
only to themselves in a few wealthy
stockholders make basic economic
decisions affecting millions of people
we believe that the workers and
consumers who are affected by economic
institutions should own
and control them own and control them
and how are you going to do that
democratic socialists damn it important
to note right off the bat most
businesses are not held by millionaires
most of them are small businesses by the
way who's most affected by said economic
institution or business maybe instead of
just the worker could it possibly be mmm
oh I don't know the business owner who
incurred all the investment in risk yet
according to the Democratic socialists
own website all of that control should
be given over to the worker why because
they said so who's going to do it the
government bureaucracy that they just
promised wouldn't happen little-known
fact it's going to be done at gunpoint
that's what government does
that's what taxes are you give us this
or men with guns come and take you away
you are one first-class idiot really you
are not like Walmart's wages but when
was the last time they gangster punked
you more over the fall of communism
should not blind us to in Justices at
home
we cannot allow all radicalism to be
dismissed as communists that suppression
of dissent and diversity undermines
America's ability to live up to its
promise of equality of opportunity not
to mention the freedoms of speech and
assembly
okay here's just the point where I'll
ask you to point me to any socialist
government that allows for freedom of
speech in the short term we can't
eliminate private corporations but we
can bring them under greater democratic
control the government could use
regulations and tax incentives to
encourage companies to act in the public
interest key detail here in the short
term we can't eliminate private
corporations which would imply in the
long term the goal is to eliminate
private corporations that sounds
familiar there with the crush the
bourgeoisie is to grind them between the
millstones of Taxation and inflation
laughs thanks cut out Lenin for
refreshing my memory so the goal is to
discourage companies from acting in the
interest of you the consumer in order to
appease the social justice worker which
is funny because it's counteracted by
another point on this very page we don't
agree with the capitalist assumption
that starvation or greed are the only
reasons people work people enjoy their
work if it is meaningful and enhances
their lives so right before this the
Democratic Socialist tell you how
they're going to force your company to
produce and operate and then in the very
next paragraph tell you oh no but we
believe that if
people are left to their own nature they
truly enjoy work specifically the work
that we force you to do people will love
the forced work we give them although a
long-term goal of socialism is to
eliminate all but the most enjoyable
kinds of labor we've recognized that
unappealing jobs footlong remain is
there anything more leftist social
justice warrior entitled millennial than
wanting to eliminate all the icky jobs
jobs like septic cleaning trash man snow
removal basically any high-paying
skilled job that Millennials refuse to
do is they pursue their eight year
degree in gender studies these tasks
could be spread among as many people as
possible rather than distributed on the
basis of class race ethnicity or gender
as they are under capitalism rather than
distributed on the basis of race class
ethnicity undercut what nothing is
distributed under capitalism
nobody says I need this trash picked up
you black man do this also I won't pay
you thank you very much that's the
beauty of free enterprise not only does
it create a truly free market of ideas
goods and services but jobs for people
who are willing to perform those jobs if
people are willing to pay them for it no
government force required which brings
us to the linchpin although no country
is fully instituted democratic socialism
the socialist parties and labor
movements of other countries have won
many victories for their people we can
learn from the comprehensive welfare
state maintained by the Swedes from
Canada's national health care system
Frances nationwide child care program
and nicaragua's literacy programs see
this is what every failed economic
system does whether it's communism
socialism socialism or democratic
socialism is oh no it would work just
nobody else has done it yet all the
other people didn't do it right but I
will and then they cherry pick data from
individual facets of countries in order
to make their point like Nicaragua's
literacy program okay why don't you talk
about their GDP Canada's nationalized
health care system why don't you talk
about the crushing debt in a Supreme
Court case that ruled it a violation of
Human Rights in 2005 Sweden it's now the
rape capital of the Western world and on
the verge of cultural and economic
collapse good for you Sweden you finally
pulled one out but that's right the
failsafe is these places weren't real
democratic social
not like these people wanted to we just
have to trust them speaking of trust
let's move to some of the most notorious
supporters of democratic socialism noted
neurosurgeons at the Young Turks and so
many people who would really benefit
from his policy ideas are against him
because they've bought into the Bernie
Sanders fear-mongering
she said fear mongering drink trigger
warning if you play that game you're
gonna get hammered they hear the word
socialist without really understanding
what it means why is it that the middle
class in the working class pays a higher
percentage of their taxable income to
the federal government and then you have
these massive multinational corporations
not paying anything in taxes um because
you're comparing corporations versus
individual income a couple of things
here under Bernie Sanders note a
Democratic Socialist the middle class
would pay more oh yeah you're making
fifty thousand a year you'd be paying
over five thousand dollars more a year
so there's that I know I know some of
you were saying but we'll get free
health care in college again if you
believe that everyone in government is
beyond corruption and those things will
happen efficiently again let's go back
to the analogy health care like the post
office only add cancer college this goes
back to the worldview what if I don't
want to go to college what if someone
decides again human nature out of their
own free will to take that job cleaning
septic tanks that Millennials refuse to
do when he gets paid well why should he
be taxed more to fund your decision to
college there's the practical and
there's the moral but back to the rocket
scientists at the Young Turks the whole
reason for lower corporate tax rates is
to avoid punishing the Umbrella so that
it has more money to give out to
individuals which ironically enough are
now taxed at a higher rate so what do
you think happens if you tax these
corporations these umbrellas more they
going to take it on the chin or fire
employees and pay them less yes we have
the highest corporate tax rate of any
developed country but when you consider
the deductions and the loopholes we have
the lowest weight which party is it
again that wants to do away with
complicated tax codes and loopholes is
it someone give me a reference
free-market means that the rich people
rigged the market in their favor no it
does not it's actually rigged by people
like Hillary Clinton Barack Obama or
would be Bernie Sanders big government
bureaucrats
get to legally determine how the system
operates again democratic socialism
necessitates trust that all of these
people are beyond corruption and will do
what's right for you which is why when
we're in the middle of economic boom
times which we are right now
corporations are making record profits
Wall Street is at record highs right off
the bat this goes back to a world view
Wall Street at record highs
so equities are the single greatest
wealth creation tool that have been
afforded to a populous since ever if you
have a 401k retirement you've invested
at all guess what you want Wall Street
to do well bailing out Wall Street is
bad we agree what Wall Street doing well
is not inherently bad for the middle
class in 2009 largely inspired by a rant
from rick santelli against the big Wall
Street bailouts tea partiers protested
big government and crony capitalism long
before Young Turks or Bernie Sanders
came around calling them racists Occupy
Wall Street they're just copycats who
smoked more weed
they rigged that system so that you
don't get to the benefit of your labor
so when even though you're working
harder producing more you don't get to
benefit you don't get to yeah you don't
get any of that money
okay democratic socialists let's fix
that how about the middle class the
middle tier workers tie their job
entirely based to performance go you
want them to benefit from their labor
proportionally to the corporation okay
now all of those employees just like the
top earners in a down year get nothing
and have to fund all of those bleak
years out of their own pockets but if
the company is successful enough to do
well despite the fact that 80% of
businesses fail the employees get paid
handsomely oh that's right
unions have opposed that for decades
better teachers should be paid more bad
teachers less now okay American
autoworkers you'll get paid more when
our reliability ratings go up and sales
go through the roof see the reason
employees are paid less and the reason
for this contract is because unlike the
business owner creator innovator you
decided to forego the risk in order to
receive financial security it's a choice
you made you didn't start the business
you didn't risk your livelihood you
collected a check regardless of annual
profits from someone who did that
disposable income are they gonna do what
millionaires and billionaires in the
United States are doing where they just
kind of poured it and they put it in
either an overseas account or any US
account and just kind of sit on it this
is so beyond stupid it defies reason how
do you think millionaires and
billionaires got to be that way by
keeping a pile of gold like Scrooge
McDuck no the only way to become
financially successful in a true free
enterprise system is through investment
and willingness to incur risk they're
gonna go out there and spend the money
they're gonna buy cars they're gonna
fortunately hopefully one day for people
like me buy a house right they're gonna
actually go into the economy and they're
gonna spend that money they're gonna go
out to eat they're gonna go out to malls
and buy gifts during Christmastime
whatever it is they spend that money
that's what stimulates the economy and
when people are buying companies are
kind of forced to hire more people so
they can deal with the demand okay but
if we're dealing with a situation where
people don't have disposable income
they're not gonna go out there and spend
anything yes yes that's what I'm talking
about
Young Turks with the grasp on basic
economics you're getting it that's
exactly a create an environment where
there are more jobs and goods and
services can be provided at an
affordable market price it's what Adam
Smith referred to as the invisible hand
the market that set prices in demand so
you're catching on as you said with
lower taxation less government red tape
putting money back in the pockets of the
consumer I'm proud of you you're being
robbed not by socialists but by the
established economic system that we've
got in America right now this video
subscribe also my producer not gay
Jarrod does find work he's in need of
employment I recommend him highly